et ce sommet du g20 on en parle avec
gilles casanova des experts en stratégie
et communication
bonjour merci d'être avec nous en direct
sur rt france alors on va parler tout
d'abord du climat on a un objectif
commun des états membres un film en
relief qui a remis le réchauffement
climatique a plus 1,5 degré je viens de
le dire ça a été réaffirmée donc ça veut
dire qu'on le savait déjà finalement
quoi de neuf
écoutez on est en face d'une saynète qui
se répète à chaque occasion on a un
président qui sur un ton de jugement
dernier annonce que la terre va
s'embraser ou à peu près et on a des
dirigeants qui promettent des choses
qu'ils ne tiennent pas une fois qu'ils
sont partis il faut dire qu'il y a des
problèmes qui sont quand même délicat
par exemple c'est 100 milliards par an
pour l'afrique quand on sait que des
organismes de coopération comme la
banque mondiale considère que c'est un
succès quand seulement 80 % de ce
qu'elle envoie est absorbée par la
corruption évidemment on comprend que
les pays occidentaux sont un peu
réticents à envoyer de telles sommes
dont ils ne savent pas à quoi elles vont
véritablement servir
d'autre part on a un jeu de
vérité ou de demi vérités entre les
divers acteurs puisque les états unis
lise tantôt que cette affaire est très
importante tantôt qu'elle n'est pas très
importante mais la réalité de ce qu'ils
font c'est qu'ils restent le premier
pollueur de là l'aneth toutes catégories
confondues on a ensuite l'écran
écologistes comme l'allemagne qui ont
arrêté le nucléaire est mis en place des
centrales à charbon et on sait par
exemple que la plus grosse de leurs
centrales à charbon produit autant de
gaz carbonique que l'ensemble du trafic
aérien français donc on voit bien qu'on
est dans une situation complexe dans
laquelle des états très différents ont
une vision très différente de ce qu'est
la réalité elle doit ce qu'est leur
puissance et l'utilisation qu'ils font
de cette question climatique pour être
un levier de leur puissance alors ceux
des vins a aussi été l'occasion
d'organiser des rencontres bilatérales
et puis il ya d'abord eu cette rencontre
un bail donne macron premier face à face
depuis la crise des sous marins ah bin
on selon vous de cette rencontre est ce
qu'ils ont fait table rase du passé pour
maintenant regarder vers l'avenir
écoutez
l'évangile conseil de tendre l'autre
joue on peut penser qu emmanuel macron a
été inspiré par l'évangile puisque après
avoir reçu une vive correction de la
part des responsables américains il a
tendu avec un sourire l'autre jour au
président américain qui a déjà
d'ailleurs fait remarquer qu'il n'avait
pas compris que la france croyait
vraiment cette affaire et se tenir
vraiment enfin quoi les enfants il faut
être sage et l'enfant a montré qu'il
était sage il a baissé la tête et puis
cette autre rencontre on continue de
parler des manières macron avec un boris
johnson était tout à l'heure à midi ça
fait deux semaines que les deux c#
autour de la pêche là on à l'élysée qui
nous dit très bien on va vers la
désescalade et puis juste à prendre un
communiqué de downing street et boris
johnson nous fait comprendre que non il
restera campait sur ses positions ça
veut dire quoi on retourne à la case
départ finalement l'entretien n'aura pas
servi à grand chose
alors vous savez dans la cour d'école
maternelle il y a ceux qui ose taper sur
les grands et puis il ya ceux qui
préfèrent taper sur les petits alors
dans cette affaire des sous marins
australiens il ya un grand c maiden via
un plus petit c'est johnson donc il faut
taper sur johnson parce que bill donne
n'est trop fort donc on prend des
positions très fermes et très dure
vis-à-vis de johnson puis on se rend
compte que c'est un peu compliqué mais
il faut avoir en tête que boris johnson
il a un pays qui a entendu avec une
certaine émotion les propos du président
français il y a un an ou deux dix ans
qu'il ferait en sorte que le bras exit
ruine le royaume uni ils n'ont pas
oublié cela donc
boris johnson n'a pas le même caractère
évangélistes que emmanuel macron et donc
n'a pas envie de tendre l'autre joue
alors plus généralement quelle est
l'utilité selon vous à de ce genre de
grandes messes
il a la faculté de permettre à des
dirigeants qui se parlent de a2 de
pouvoir se parler dans des formes ou des
formats selon le terme des diplomates
qui sont très variés ne peut se
rencontrer à 3 à 4 à 5 en fonction des
centres d'intérêt et donc ça permet
d'avoir une intense activité
diplomatique non seulement entre les
présidents mais entre les conseillers
des présidents et les ministres des
affaires étrangères qui peuvent se
trouver là donc ça a
et intérêts pour ce qui se passe dans la
coulisse sur la scène c'est comme tout
les opérettes la première fois qu'on
voit l'auberge du cheval blanc on trouve
que c'est charmant la troisième ou la
quatrième fois on sait d'avancé comment
ça se termine et puis on finit par
savoir les détails même du livre est
expert en stratégie et communication
merci à vous d'avoir été en direct sur
rt france merci